the Marvel Cinematic Universe is a
complicated place where just about
everything is way more important than it
initially seems including dialogue these
are some of the most significant
exchanges that slip by audiences at the
time only to leave a major impact on
them later on in Avengers infinity war
Tony Stark confronts Thanos Sun Titan
only to be addressed by name when he
asks it the mad Titan knows him Thanos
responds I do you're not the only one
cursed with knowledge the line is
clearly dripping with deeper meaning but
the obvious question is how does Stannis
know Tony Stark the commentary track for
the movie answered that question when
screenwriter Christopher Markus
explained you realize this interesting
parallel between Thanos and Tony they're
both aware of something from an early
points and constantly having to deal
with being smarter Thanos is a futurist
as much as Tony Stark the connection
between the two while it has its limits
certainly explains why the mad Titan
would gravitate towards Stark is a
fellow being that struggles with the big
issues but what about the fact that he
addressed him by name co-director Joe
Russo cleared that one up by explaining
that Thanos his quotes aware of Stark
from the original Battle of New York as
the person who undid the plan this
double whammy of Stark initially getting
Thanos attention with a nuke and then
connecting with him as a fellow genius
certainly goes a long way in explaining
why the mad Titan would have such
respect for his opponents phase 1 of the
MCU was a formative time as many of the
basic elements and unofficial laws of
how things work were established and
fleshed out one of those unofficial laws
has to do with the difference between
magic and science and it's initially
laid out by Thor during his first solo
outing at one point in the movie the god
of thunder and Jane Foster have a
conversation in which Thor explains that
your ancestors called it magic and you
call it science well I come from a place
where that one in the same thing the
line uttered while the two characters
are making eyes at one another is
deceptively important under the surface
and ends up being a huge mantra going
forward it doesn't matter if you're
dealing with Infinity stones vibranium
from Wakanda or pretty much anything
Doctor Strange does most magical moments
are eventually explained away in
scientific terms at some point or
another whatever the situation there's
no doubt at this point that the overlap
between science and magic has firmly
embedded itself is one
the MC use guiding principles at one
point in Avengers age of Ultron Tony
Stark and Bruce Banner are seen
discussing a new form of artificial
intelligence recovered from von
strucker's Hydra back to research the to
debate as stark insists that he wants to
harness the potential power of the AI in
order to run his iron Legion as a form
of protection for the world remember
this all takes place after the group
defends Earth from an invasion of
Chitauri aliens and Avengers
it also comes after stark is given a
disturbing vision by Scarlet Witch in
which he sees death and destruction
brought on by another galactic attack at
one point in the conversation stark says
I see a suit of armor around the world
the line slips by fairly quickly and is
mostly forgotten after Ultron emerges
and becomes a threat but the idea of a
global suit of armor as a protection
against extraterrestrial threats never
quite disappears in fact Stark's dream
of defending the earth becomes a primary
theme and is gradually unfolding
showdown with Thanos as the iron Avenger
attempts to do everything in his power
to stop the mad Titan the relationship
between the Tasha Romanoff and Clint
Barton is legendary at this point but
it's never on better display than it was
during the airport fight scene in
Captain America Civil War as all the
heroes split off and fight each other
who should find themselves face to face
but the pair of X shield agents they
engage in a pleasantly entertaining
comparativemarkerselection
the scene is a light-hearted break from
the serious events of the film and
showcases the enduring friendship of the
duo however it isn't until Avengers
endgame that the gravity of those lines
really hits home when Romanoff and
Barton had the form ear it turns out
that their love for each other is
exactly what is needed in order for
Black Widow to give her life in order to
gain the soul stone an event that also
involves some hard hitting as they fight
over who will make the sacrifice one of
the best sequences in the entire MCU
takes place during Thor's time on Sekar
in Thor Ragnarok each scene is filled
with tongue-in-cheek slapstick humor as
stor aka sparkles
finds himself trapped by the Grand
Master and forced to fight his champion
fortunately that champion ends up being
than Thor's old friend and Co Avenger
Hulk Thor's reaction when he sees the
Jade giant entered the arena is
priceless his look of concern melts away
as he cheers adding it's already one of
the funniest lines in the entire movie
which is saying something but the
background behind how it came into being
makes it even better it turns out the
line wasn't invented by the writers
director or even Thor star Chris
Hemsworth in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly Hemsworth explained
that what is arguably the most iconic
line from the entire movie was actually
thought up by a child from the
make-a-wish Foundation who was on the
set when they filmed the scene priceless
when Thanos plucks the mind stone out of
visions head in the waning moments of
infinity war his victory seems both
imminence and inevitable that is until
Thor suddenly arrives hurling
Stormbreaker at the unsuspecting villain
and catching him off guard the weapon
strikes him in the chest and Thor drops
down in its wake in order to gloat in
his apparent victory but of course we
all know what happens next
[Music]
while the repercussions of that line are
pretty obvious there's one hidden side
effect that isn't quite so easy to spot
obviously Thor's choice to prioritize
his own gloating over simply killing
Thanos on-site meant half of the
universe perished and all of the pain
and loss of Avengers endgame had to
follow but another unexpected result
came in the form of Thor's physical
appearance and dejected condition in the
fourth Avengers film in the beginning of
the movie Thor ends up going for the
head decapitating a helpless Thanos in a
fit of angry vengeance but as writers
Markus and McFeely pointed out that very
action turns out to be a failure that
breaks his will completely one of the
most iconic lines from Marvel Comics is
Avengers Assemble the phrase was
anxiously anticipated throughout the
first Avengers film but never surfaced
in Avengers age of Ultron it became
clear that director Joss Whedon was
playfully avoiding the line after all
how can we forget that ending
all of which serves to underscore why it
was a pretty big deal when at the climax
of his avenging career Captain America
finally at long last uh turd those two
words before the decisive battle at the
end of Avengers endgame surrounded by a
host of heroes who had just joined him
at the last second via a myriad of sling
rings it was the absolute perfect time
for the phrase to finally find its way
onto the big screen Avengers Assemble
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 is a fun
trip to follow us a Guardians team as
they grow closer as a family it also
introduces mantas reboots Groot as baby
Groot and sees yondu pull of Mary
Poppins it also also has an important
teaser at the very end of it all in the
form of a new character one of the
film's end credits scenes shows Aisha
the High Priestess of the sovereign as
she is about to be held accountable by
the sovereign council for wasting
resources she has one last trick up her
sleeve as she admires an elaborate
golden birthing pod that rests before
her what's inside according to Aisha is
a next step in our evolution more
powerful beautiful capable of destroying
the guardians of the galaxy she goes on
to come up with a name for this new
being I think I shall call him
the person being referenced is a
powerful Adam warlock a comic-book
character that Marvel fans have been
hoping to see for quite a while now
chances are we'll see warlocks sooner
rather than later as guardians of the
galaxy three is officially on the docket
not only that but James got us back to
helm the project giving warlock and even
greater likelihood of getting in on the
action
he's a favorite character of the
director I am Iron Man
four simple words at this point we've
got pretty used to hearing them but when
one stops to think about their impact on
Tony Stark's storyline not to mention
the MCU as a whole it's a bit staggering
right from the get-go Tony Stark was
drawn toward the phrase uttering it
during his first solo outing to the
amazement of a room full of reporters
the line shows up again in Iron Man 3
this time expanded we can take away my
house all my tricks and toys
one thing we can't take away I am Iron
Man the words are a rallying point for
Starks identity there are a way to sum
up his entire persona it's also a
concept that comes to its ultimate
fruition at the very end of the Infinity
Saga after all the dramatic events in
the war with Thanos as he kneels with
the Infinity stones in hand and his
fingers ready to snap away the mad
Titans entire existence what four words
to start choose to use you've heard him
before in the early moments of Captain
America the First Avenger the Red Skull
is shown leading a raid on a Norwegian
village in search of the tesseract the
cube secretly containing an infinity
stone ultimately ends up going on to
play a key role in Captain Marvel's
origin story before it's used by both
Thanos and the Avengers during the
events of an infinity war in endgame but
it doesn't take those world-shaking
events for the Nazi villain to
understand what he has in his possession
as he stands looking at the stone in
amazement Red Skull simply utters the
line could very well be a reference not
only to Hitler's fascination with the
occult but it could also be an homage to
the Indiana Jones movies which featured
Nazis searching for both the Ark of the
Covenant and the Holy Grail in the
desert do in these adventures secretly
take place within the MCU well no duh
but either way referring to an artifact
that can obliterate your enemies as a
trinket is a pretty bold way to let
savvy audience members who picked up on
the line know that they're dealing with
some pretty powerful stuff Captain
America the First Avenger ended up being
a critical part of the MCU as it said in
motion one of the most important
storylines of the entire Infinity Saga
the story traced Steve Rogers on his
path from a physically weak morally
strong young man to a full-blown super
soldier with the weight of the world on
his shoulders but for all the heroics
one of the best lines in the entire film
wasn't about Rogers a superhero as much
as Rogers the romantic as the film's
World War 2 action wraps up Rogers wakes
up nearly 70 years in the future having
spent the last several decades in Nice
induced coma bewildered the hero runs
out into a bustling city street and is
confronted by none other than Nick Fury
who informs him of how long he's been
asleep he looks around taking in the
shocking news at everything he ever knew
lies three-quarters of a century in the
past fury asks Steve if he's okay too
which Rodgers responds yeah yeah I just
I had a date this of course is a
reference to his romantic relationship
with Peggy Carter which had so suddenly
been cut off while the line was moving
on its own it ultimately meant quite a
bit more when a ventures endgame rolled
around at the end of that film Rodgers
heads back in time blowing past his
timestamp in order to finally at long
last fulfill that date with agent Carter
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff for coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]